السؤال هنا هل يمكن ان تخطئ المانيا مجددا
فعل اعتمادها على الصين في الصناعه كما
فعلت مع روسيا في الغاز وابقى دراسه
نشرتها روديوم جروب المتخصصه في الابحاث
في الصين فيما يخص القطاع الخاص تعملوا
5000 شركه المانيه في الصين الاقتصاد
الالمانيه اصبح اكثر اعتمادا على الصين في
النصف الاول من عام 2022 وفقا لبحثا
الماني طلعت عليه وكاله رويترز المعهد
الاقتصادي الالماني اشار الى ان الصناعه
الالمانيه استثمرت حوالي عشره مليارات
يورو في الصين في النصف الاول من هذا
العام وحده رقم القياسيه
قد تظن ان الارقام توضح اعتماد الصين على
صناعه المانيا لكن خبراء المان لديهم ما
وجهه نظر مختلفه يمكن لبكينا النصر نسخه
ما نصدره اليها
وبسهوله وهذه براعه صينيه تقليديه لكن مره
اخرى هل ستفعل المانيا في الصين اما لم
تفعله مع روسيا
لونج انجليزي